Hey,
did you see tiger yesterday?
Dude,
I was watching it while we were in Georgia.
We were in Georgia for the UFC and I had a comedy show out there and we were me
and um,
Santino or watching it on the screen.
Ah,
on Saturday or yesterday.
We watched it Friday or was it Friday or Saturday?
Saturday.
So Friday,
Saturday,
and then he won yesterday.
Well,
whatever days it was,
right.
I think we watched it two days in a row.
It was in the gym every day we were there,
but then I got home and I saw it on my phone.
I was like,
Holy Shit,
I don't even give a fuck about golf.
I know I'm able to speak powerful.
I made a comeback,
a huge comeback with that.
I mean that's amazing.
Are 11 years later,
oh my God,
those selling somebody's put on Instagram.
One of my quotes that I attached to that,
it was pretty cool that I love a guy,
get a like I love,
what did I say?
I love a success story,
but even more than that,
I love a guy fucked his life up and then gets it back together again.
Story.
It's the greatest,
it's the greatest.
When you realize like how much of us good must field to that guy,
top of the world again.
And then he like,
yeah,
I'm so messed up.
And then the back problems and troubles in the kids and the wife and the thing
and just 11 years.
Yup.
And he didn't stop working.
He just went to work and went to work and went to where he is 11 years later.
And so he won a major championship recently,
right?
Didn't he won when one,
it was a big deal.
He won a major championship within the last,
it wasn't a manager,
but it was,
it wasn't a major this,
this was the first major.
He's one in 11 years.
Okay.
So the other one wasn't a major,
but it was a big event.
It was a big tournament.
He wins that one.
Everybody's like,
wow,
he might be back.
He can,
he can fucking win big tournament's again.
And then he just,
Oh,
it was so cool to see.
The crowd just kept building over the weekend and by yesterday it was massive.
Thousands of people around the green just hanging on him.
Oh,
the relief that you saw just coming out of him was so great.
And then at the end,
like he walks off where as a kid he was only like 21 when he were on the first
time hugging his dad at the edge.
And now he comes off 11 years later,
all this time.
And His dad's passed and he's hugging his child,
his son.
Now he's the father in the same spot.
Oh.
It was just,
I was trying not to cry the whole time.
Oh,
it was such a tear jerker what relief.
People were just so happy for him.
Wow.
Such a great story.
We do love a comeback.
Why not man?
You love a comeback.
We,
we're all flawed like you were saying before.
But yeah,
man,
being able to improve,
that's what that guy,
did he have it down in and pre improved.